desde este domingo en la tarde de los
judíos celebran el rosh hashaná su año
nuevo que da paso al año 5.783 del
calendario hebreo y como se tenía ha
iniciado con cierta violencia en torno a
la Explanada de las mezquitas Aunque el
lugar está dedicado al culto musulmán en
una fecha como ésta Se agudiza la
presencia de judíos que lo consideran su
lugar más sagrado debido a esto desde
temprano agentes ingresaron para
desplazar a los palestinos Incluyendo a
un grupo de jóvenes que según la policía
israelí se atrincheró en la mezquita de
alacsa y arrojó fuegos artificiales y
piedras los policías israelíes
estuvieron al menos eso de cuatro
personas dos en La Explanada y dos en la
cercana puerta de los leones y
desalojaron por la fuerza a varias otras
en videos difundidos por redes sociales
se observa el uso de algunos gases
lacrimógenos y de empujones de los
agentes israelíes incluso a personas
mayores y miembros de la media luna roja
Palestina además escoltaron a grupos de
judíos que ingresaron al predio algunos
de ellos orando una acción que violar
está tu de los lugares sagrados de
Jerusalén frente a estas incursiones el
grupo islamista jamás sé que gobierna en
la franja de gaza amenazó de nuevo con
repercusiones a que podrían desencadenar
según sus palabras una gran batalla
previendo este escenario el gobierno
israelí anunció un refuerzo de la
vigilancia en carreteras y asentamientos
israelíes en Jordania ocupada además de
un cierre de los pasos fronterizos y
Jordania y gasa hasta el martes lo que
para los palestinos se traduce en una
mayor limitación de sus movimientos